Donald Trump had a rally in the Super
Tuesday state of North Carolina and he
went into a bizarre diatribe because of
a potentially Mexican audience member
and in the video you're going to see
Donald Trump point to someone in the
audience and start to say he's Mexican
and then he says but wait are you
Mexican no way you're Mexican you are
you aren't no way that guy is Mexican
he's as Mexican as I am it's genuinely
hard to tell whether Donald Trump is
shocked that there might really be a
Mexican person at one of his rallies
maybe it's a light-skinned Mexican which
Donald Trump might not know exists
Donald Trump not particularly familiar
with Central and South America I don't
know what's going on here but it is very
very weird the dhol where do you live
like this guy he's a Mexican you're
about as Mexican as I am look at this
guy he's as Mexican as I am look at that
hat are you Mexican are you Mexican no
you're not
are you he is it's like Elizabeth Warren
she said she was in India and I said
right I said I have more Indian blood in
me than you have and I have none and she
said oh this is terrible so she went out
and got a test and it turned out not so
good for her right extremely strange and
of course has to throw in Elizabeth
Warren Indian references as well can you
guys believe that this is the world that
we're in today that this is what we're
living in in 2020 the president ranting
and raving about a possibly Mexican
audience member is it notable this of
course is upper Trump as we discussed
yesterday with psychiatrist dr. Justin
Frank this reminds me of when Donald
Trump spotted a black guy in the
audience and started to yell about my
african-american remember this abortive
rally from the campaign we had a case
where we had an african-american guy who
is a fan of mine great fan great guy in
fact I want to find out what's going on
with him you know what a look at my
african-american over here look at him
are you the greatest do you know what
I'm talking about okay so we have an
african-american guy at one of the
rallies a month ago this is sort of a
concept for rally mitts
Trump used to just read poll numbers
totally out of context at rallies a new
direction to go would be evaluate the
perceived Wraiths inocent ethnicity of
people in the crowd maybe turn it into
some kind of game show because that's
effectively what we're dealing with
right now and then of course we got to
the moment in the rally when Donald
Trump glitched glitching this time
specifically on the word banker you'll
hear it if you're watching you'll also
see that shoulder spasm that we
discussed yesterday with psychiatrist
dr. Justin Frank talked about that
phenomenon that is often notable with
Trump take a look so they don't have to
go back to the evil banker and borrow
money from the banker and lose the farm
lose the business
it won't happen and I always say it
because you know I know a lot of parents
another day another glitch and then
lastly this is almost satirical at this
point Trump bragged about yesterday's of
the day before yesterday's large
increase in the stock market ignoring of
course that it was an erratic rebound
from last week's fastest 10 percent
decline in the stock market in history
which Trump blamed on the democratic
debate then here is Trump taking credit
for the erratic rebound day that the
stock market had this is an incredible
time for our nation our country is
stronger than ever before and today we
just had the largest one-day increase in
the stock market in history
imagine cheering for that the fastest
10% decrease ever the week before you
get a partial rebound followed by the
way yesterday with another thousand
point loss and Trump has the crowd
cheering about the one day in the
interlude of erratic stock market
insanity and they're just cheering and
absolutely loving it and then by the way
here's Trump yesterday yesterday the
stock market crashed again Trump asked
about it he says oh no I have it I
haven't seen the numbers I haven't seen
it I'm focused on this the country is in
great shape the market is in great shape
I'm focused on this this is very
important what luck right Trump only has
the availability and the time in his
schedule to follow the stock market on
days where the stock market is up
amazing coincidence
so anyway another Trump rally filled
with what you would expect to hear from
the senile guys that go to your local
watering hole at 10:30 p.m. on a Tuesday
night more so than what would be suited
for a presidential rally and a President
of the United States this is where we
are in 2020 the way the primary is going
we may be in this situation until
January of 2025 as utterly insane as
that sounds
Trump would be what 78 at that point in
time this is scary stuff and I'm worried
that that's the direction in which we
are going real quick I want to tell you
about a YouTube channel called up flip
they're friends of our show you can
check them out by going to david
pakman.com slash up flip the link is
down below underneath the video every
week up flip publishes a new video where
you get to meet an entrepreneur learn
about the business they built see what
it's like to live a day in their shoes
in that business I love learning about
small business owners the steps they
took to become successful that's why I
love the content on up flip you'll get
an exclusive look at some really
fascinating businesses each entrepreneur
has many valuable insights and
strategies to share about how to build
and maintain a successful company I
would highly recommend their two-part
series
lean manufacturing which itself is a
really interesting concept that's all
about sort of minimizing waste
maximizing efficiency and up flip breaks
it all down you can get to their channel
by going to david pakman.com slash up
flip the link is right below this video
make sure you subscribe to their channel
and click that Bell icon so you'll be
notified when they upload new videos